in this video we're going to think about
constructing lewis diagrams which you've
probably seen before they're nice ways
of visualizing how the atoms in a
molecule are bonded to each other and
what other lone pairs of valence
electrons various atoms might have
and so let's just start with an example
then we'll come up with some rules for
trying to draw these lewis diagrams so
the first example that we will look at
is silicon
tetrafluoride
and tetrafluoride is just a fancy way of
saying four fluorines so tetrafluoride
now the first step is to say well what
are the electrons that are of interest
to us and if we're talking about the
electrons that are likely to react we're
talking about the valence electrons so v
period e period for short valence
electrons so first let's just think
about how many total valence electrons
are involved in silicon tetrafluoride
well to think about that we could think
about how many valence electrons the
silicon have and then how many valence
electrons does each of the fluorines
have if they were just three atoms in
neutral and then multiply that times
four because you have four fluorines so
let's get out our periodic table of
elements
and then you can see here that silicon
its outer shell is the third shell and
in that third shell it has one two three
four valence electrons
so silicon here has four valence
electrons
and then to that we're going to add the
valence electrons from the four
fluorines a free neutral fluorine atom
its outer shell is the second shell and
in that outer shell it has one two three
four five six seven electrons so each of
these fluorines has seven valence
electrons but there are four of them
so one silicon tetrafluoride molecule is
going to have four plus 28 valence
electrons so this is going to be a total
of 32.
now the next step is to think about how
might these be configured
and as a general rule of thumb we'd want
to put the least electronegative atom
that is not hydrogen at the center
and we've talked about this before but
you can even see from the periodic table
of elements fluorine is actually the
most electronegative element and so we
would at least try to put silicon at the
center and make fluorine a terminal atom
something on the outside so let's try to
do that so let's put silicon
in the center and then we have to put
the four fluorine someplace let's just
put one fluorine there one fluorine
there one fluorine there and one
fluorine there
now the next step is well let's just say
for simplicity that we just have single
bonds between the silicon and each of
the fluorines so let's do that so one
bond a bond a bond a bond
now each of these covalent bonds each of
these lines in our lewis diagram they
represent two electrons so for example
this one right over here that i'm doing
in yellow that represents two electrons
that are shared by this fluorine and
this silicon this represents another two
electrons that is shared between this
fluorine and the silicon there's another
two electrons that's shared between this
fluorine and this silicon and this is
another two electrons shared between
that fluorine and the silicon
so so far how many electrons have we
accounted for well each of these
represent two electrons so 2 4 6 8
electrons
so if we subtract 8 from this we are
left with 24 electrons to account for 24
valence electrons
so now
our general rule of thumb would be try
to put those on those terminal atoms
with the goal of getting those terminal
atoms to having eight valence electrons
and in general we try to get the octet
rule for any atom except for hydrogen
hydrogen you just need to get to two in
that outer shell but fluorine you want
to get it to eight it already has two
that it can share so it needs six more
so let's add that two
four
six
let's do that again for this fluorine
two
four
six
do it again for this fluorine two
four
six and then last but not least for this
fluorine 2
4
and 6. now how many more electrons are
now accounted for well 6 in this
fluorine 6 in this fluorine 6 and this
fluorine 6 in this fluorine so 6 times
four we've now accounted for 24 more
electrons we've now used up all of the
valence electrons
now that's good because we want to
account for all of the valence electrons
we want to represent them somehow in
this lewis diagram the next thing to
check for is how satisfied the various
elect the various atoms are relative to
the octet rule we've already seen that
the fluorines are feeling pretty good
they each have six electrons that are
not in a bond and then they're able to
share two electrons that are in a bond
so each of them can kind of feel like
they have eight outer electrons eight
valence electrons hanging out with them
and then the silicon is able to share in
four bonds each of those bonds have two
electrons so the silicon is also feeling
good about the octet rule so i would
feel very confident in this being the
lewis diagram sometimes called the lewis
structure for silicon tetrafluoride so
just to hit the point home on what we
just did i will give you these steps but
hopefully you find them pretty intuitive
that's what i didn't want to show you
from the beginning but as you see step
one was find the total number of valence
electrons we did that that's the four
from silicon and then the 28 from the
fluorines
it says add an electron for every
negative charge subtract an electron for
every positive charge we didn't have to
do that in this example because it's a
neutral molecule then it says decide the
central atom which should be the least
electronegative except for hydrogen
that's why we pick silicon because
fluorine is the most electronegative
atom and then we drew the bonds we saw
that the bonds accounted for eight
electrons and we subtracted those
electrons from the total in step one and
that's just to keep track of the number
of valence electrons that we are
accounting for and then we had 24 left
over and then the next step it says
assign the valence electrons to the
terminal atoms that's where we assign
these extra lone pair electrons to the
various fluorines giving them an extra
six each so that they were all able to
fulfill the octet rule and then we
subtracted that from the total really
just to account to make sure that we're
using all of our electrons it says it
right here subtract the electrons from
the total instep do and then we saw that
all of our electrons were accounted for
but then in step four it says if
necessary assign any leftover electrons
to the central atom we didn't have to do
that in this example if the central atom
has an octet or exceeds an octet you are
usually done in this case it had an
octet so we felt done and it finally
says if a central atom does not have an
octet create multiple bonds once again
in this example we were able to stay
pretty simple with just single bonds but
in future examples we're going to see
where we might have to do some of these
more nuanced steps so i will leave you
there and i'll see you in the next
example